David what kind of changes have you have
you witnessed down there I mean how do
you feel the state of New Orleans is
today I've been back here a number of
times since that storm Matt and every
time it seems like there's been more and
more progress so you notice things the
very physical sense there's a new
hospital that opened up that went to
take a look at for instance but you also
notice as Mitch Landrieu was alluding to
there how much stuff has changed here
structurally so they just talked about
the school district here that was after
the storm all the closed-down
tons of teachers were fired it was a
recovery school district for a time and
now you see a city with a huge amount of
charter schools like nowhere else in
this country the same sort of
reinvention happened with the healthcare
system here many more clinics than there
were before so just everywhere you look
the place looks different and as
Mitchell Andy was saying there is there
does seem to be this palpable sense of
momentum moving forward David Michael
Bloomberg of course the founder of
Bloomberg LP in the former New York City
Mayor
he wrote a Bloomberg view column about
what was going on in New Orleans and I'd
like to read part of it it's entitled a
decade later New Orleans men's finances
and neighborhoods it says New Orleans
has a long way to go to improve economic
opportunity for all of its residents but
in each case the city is embracing as
the mayor wrote imaginative and
innovative policies that have brought it
back from the brink of collapse and
offer hope for what the next 10 years
will bring
mayor Landrieu basically told you the
same thing this is an enormous
undertaking what type of help is New
Orleans getting from the private sector
to accomplish its goals
a ton of it and so as mayor Landrieu
alluded to there he's had a lot of
support from foundations private
foundations who saw the needs here New
Orleans came down here offered to help
so a lot of target investment in
education in healthcare that continues
there's also just been a huge amount of
focus on finding new ways to take this
economy in different directions so you
think about the New Orleans economy
historically tourism has been huge
petrochemicals transportation education
there's a sense now that there has to be
something different to add to that
biotechnology digital technology these
are things that the city and the state
have invested very heavily in trying to
get more companies to come here trying
to make this a hotbed for both of those
things so just walking around there's
now a new neighborhood called the bio
district in a very nascent stage as
everybody told me here I mentioned that
hospital that we visited a couple of
days ago that's a huge facility 2.3
million square feet and around that the
city hopes will see the growth of a lot
of small companies and that will give
rise to bigger companies thinking that
New Orleans is a place where they could
relocate you know one of the most
important one of the most important
prerequisites for investment is the rule
of law and New Orleans wasn't a terribly
safe place before Katrina after the
storm it was incredibly dangerous a lot
of crime how have they turned that
around because I know that they've done
a great job in fighting crime and making
it a safer place for tourists and and
businesses
you know it's it's still very much a
focus mayor Landrieu said that you know
there still is a lot more work to be
done especially when you look at the
city's murder rate the amount of crime
that's down a bit but still not to where
he wants to see it and certainly we're
not everybody wants to see it when you
talk about corruption other aspects of
doing business in the city mayor
Landrieu emphatic that there needs to be
more transparency still even as he's
encouraged that in his first term now
into a second that's still gonna be very
much a focus of his he says going
forward alright David thanks very much
for that Bloomberg David Gura they're
coming to us from New Orleans he's got
special reports that you can check out
on our website as well at Bloomberg comm
definitely very interesting work that
he's done down there the whole week
kinda hard to believe it's been ten
years that went by really really fast
and New Orleans has come a long way but
as the mayor mentioned as David told us
still have a long ways to go but you
know they have faith it's a great
American city they'll do what they can
to bring it back to life